[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: I'm
here with Maurice,
who is part of the-- a software
engineer on the Flutter, team,
and he's particularly focused
on the plugins and ecosystem
part of Flutter.
So I know that you've worked
a lot on the Firebase plugins.
Is there a particular
Firebase plugin
that you think is
especially underappreciated
that should have some
more love, more usage?
MAURICE PARRISH: Yeah, I really
like the Firebase Dynamic Links
plugin.
With that plugin, it
makes it really easy
to navigate to the part of
your app that you really like.
And combined with
Flutter's route
and how easy it is to
navigate with Flutter,
I think it fits really
well inside the ecosystem.
EMILY FORTUNA: So
how would you combine
Dynamic Links with the
route navigation in Flutter?
MAURICE PARRISH: So
since you would just
go to the Firebase website,
you get your configuration file
for your Android and your
iOS, just plug that in,
and then you include the
dependency and your [INAUDIBLE]
spec and everything.
Then after that,
all you have to do
is just retrieve
the Dynamic Link,
and then you just parse it.
And then you can
use the navigation
with pushes and routes to set
up automatic navigation when
your app starts.
So it's really just
straightforward to implement.
EMILY FORTUNA: Do
you have any advice
for people who are looking
to create new plugins
or packages for Flutter?
MAURICE PARRISH:
I would definitely
look at the language guide
for an effective Dart.
Looking at that language guide
really helps you not only learn
a lot about all the--
Dart and all its
features, it helps
you write a lot cleaner code.
And also looking at the
language guide makes it--
help your app get
a lot more exposure
by following those guides.
Because when we run the
test on the plugin website,
we run through a
lot of Dart format
and how you implement
certain things.
EMILY FORTUNA: It's true.
And also I know that
the score that you
see on the package on pub, when
you're looking at packages,
is partly based on if it's
following proper style guides.
MAURICE PARRISH:
Yes, definitely.
It looks through to make sure--
it basically runs a
Dart format, which
is a plug-in tool you can
already use to automatically
format your code.
And then it just makes sure
your dependencies are you--
all your dependencies are use.
They're lined up right and a
lot of other checks as well.
EMILY FORTUNA: Makes your
code more readable as well.
Is there any particular
package or plugin
that you would like to see
that doesn't exist yet?
MAURICE PARRISH: For
me, I'd definitely
like to see a plug-in
for a graphics engine.
Right now, for my
own personal project,
I'm making a game with the
Flame plugin, the really basic
2D graphics engine.
But I would like to see
a fully fleshed out one.
I think that'd be really
great for a lot of developers.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Maurice, thank you
so much for chatting with us.
This has been great.